el Líbano se enfrenta por primera vez en
su historia a un vacío total del poder
legislativo es decir que no hay
presidente ni un gobierno hoy se ha
celebrado la quinta sesión parlamentaria
para Designar al nuevo jefe de estado
que ha sido una sesión fallida después
de que Michelle aún haya terminado su
mandato de 6 años el 1 de noviembre pero
una vez más su señorías han puesto por
encima sus intereses personales al
interés común de la nación y no ha
habido consenso para elegir un nuevo
presidente a la crisis política se suma
la profunda crisis económica por lo que
no hay buenos augurios para el futuro
del Líbano 3.000 millones de dólares
siguen congelados en el fondo monetario
internacional a la espera de que Líbano
emprenda reformas económicas pero con un
vacío total de poder difícilmente podrán
cumplir con sus compromisos a todo esto
hay que Añadir un nuevo brote de cólera
el primero en 30 años que es ya una
pandemia con más de 1.500 casos
registrados desde que se detectó el
primer caso a principios de octubre la
respuesta internacional ha sido rápida y
hoy han llegado más de 600.000 dosis de
la vacuna contra el cólera pero no es
suficiente para poder llegar a toda la
población vulnerable que representa ya
el 80% en el Líbano